[guns fire]
NARRATOR: At the end
of January, 1968,
Saigon was alive
with a festive spirit
as everyone prepared for
the Tet Lunar New Year.
[thrilling music]
It was to be the first spring of
the Second Republic of Vietnam.
The Tet truce proposed by the
communist North Vietnamese
seemed to promise the
people a safe holiday,
free from the ever-present
anxiety of war.
At the temple, the
people gathered to pay
respects to their ancestors.
On the eve of the New Year,
thousands of Saigon families
prayed before altars
of their ancestors.
They prayed that peace might
be restored to their homeland.
This year, however, the
traditional firecrackers
of the Tet celebration
became the fireworks of war.
The Viet Cong, taking advantage
of the noisy celebration,
launched a savage attack on
Saigon, violating the truce
they themselves had proposed.
[guns fire]
Areas of the city became
a blazing inferno.
[guns fire]
Columns of smoke rose
skywards as block after block
in the capital city burned
with the fires of Viet Cong
treachery.
[guns fire]
As frightened people
fled, many fell
victim to the enemy gunfire.
This carefully planned attack
by the North Vietnamese
has been described as
their all-or-nothing
go for broke effort.
It ended in 10 communists
dead for each allied soldier
lost, the tremendous
price they paid
for their desperate attempt.
[guns fire]
When the fires
subsided, the residents
returned into the
ashes of their homes
and sadly shuffled
through the ruins
to salvage what they could.
Many of these people had
been born in these houses
and had reared their
children in them.
Now there was nothing left
but ashes and memories.
[somber music]
[helicopter rumbles]